the severity of this year's flu season
is adding urgency to scientific efforts
to fight the virus more than 14,000
people have been hospitalized with the
flu this season and that is the highest
number in nearly a decade
it's killed at least 53 children so far
including two right here in New York
City in the past week and while the flu
vaccine is on average 40 to 60 percent
effective the season's effectiveness may
be closer to just 17 percent dr. David
agus joins us the table to discuss David
we're so glad you're here because I
don't know anybody that isn't worried
about the flu thinking about the flu and
thinking that once you get it it could
be a death sentence put it in
perspective for us about how bad or how
serious it is well to tell you how sir
it is Gayle King got a flu shot there
because healthy people are dying from
the flu yeah you know nineteen seventeen
eighty plus million people died of the
flu so flu has always been here this
year is a bad strain compared to other
years you know it comes in droplets so
when we speak droplets go out and virus
can spread just by speaking to somebody
and then your body makes an immune
response against the flu the immune
response is what makes you feel sick and
when immune responses are really
profound and big that can actually make
you be hospitalized and we've seen it
healthy people in their teens 20s and
30s hospitalized and died in a day or
two but you're saying healthy people
always die from the flu every year they
died from the flu this year's flu strain
h3n2 is particularly difficult because
it's not great with any vaccine and
because it's particularly virulent so we
know you're supposed to get the vaccine
what else are you supposed to do I mean
should people think about masks should
they be using hand sanitizer what should
they be doing well you know in Asia
people wear masks not to prevent getting
the flu so they don't spread it to
somebody else so it's the respect if you
put it on when you have it but stay home
and so we're seeing and I'm tough I'm
just gonna go to work and they need me
at work and what happens is you spread
it to two or three people they spread it
to ten or twenty and it goes around take
care of other people stay home if you
feel sick
we know that taking the vaccine can also
lessen the effects if you end up getting
the flu and yet I looked this up this
morning only four states require
preschoolers to get a flu vaccine to
enter daycare should we be thinking
about mandating the flu vaccine I'm a
believer and I think there's no downside
I do believe is that
flu vaccines even in a bad year like
this year whether it's ten twenty thirty
percent effective in the US will see but
it helps you if you had the flu vaccine
and you get a strain not in the vaccine
the severity of the flu you get won't be
as great so all of us should have it and
to protect everybody else
we shouldn't mandate it because that
woman around the corner who's elderly or
that child we have to protect them also
all right dr. Dave a it's good to have
you here dresses enough